it gives me a great pleasure to join all
of you at the launch of this inaugural
Nobel Prize Series conference in
Singapore I'm not here to make you feel
comfortable I'm here to make you think
the student can know much more than the
teacher in my opinion is a very positive
it's very important to me because as
soon that's focusing onto the sciences
teachers must be able to identify those
people who follow their passion who do
curious things who really want to to do
different to make a difference in the
end some brilliant points have been
brought up around the table very
insightful worth of this than from
Dolores at almost a pians has made its
interminable search for self-fulfillment
upliftment through intellectual
transformation which is my reading of
education the depth of your thought is
very important to to listen to it get in
to attend lectures like this amazing
and a big skull thank you